pour la première fois le gouvernement
décide d'ouvrir les archives sur la
répression sanglante de la manifestation
d'algériens d'octobre 69 réactions
mitigées des syndicats de police les
tests génétiques effectuées à pleine
fougères sont négatifs pour tenter
d'identifier le meurtrier de caroline
dickinson
une deuxième série de tests concernera
les hommes plus âgés ou congo scènes de
joie et de pillages à brazzaville
après cinq mois de guerre civile le
nouvel homme fort dénis sassou nguesso
accorde une interview exclusive à nous
enlever les solutions donner la parole
aux plus démunis à l'occasion de la
journée mondiale du refus de la misère
l' enquête de la rédaction
témoignage en france et à madrid madame
monsieur bonsoir l'ouverture des
archives annoncé hier par catherine
trautmann ministre de la culture devrait
permettre de faire la vérité sur cette
nuit du 17 octobre 61 ou une
manifestation d'algériens durement
réprimée a fait de nombreuses victimes
jamais comptabilisés dans les bilans
officiels
cette décision de lever le secret sur
des documents qui dorment depuis 36 ans
suscite des réactions mitigées des
syndicats de police reste que cette
décision donnera en même temps un nouvel
éclairage sur la responsabilité de
maurice papon alors préfet de police
philippe boisserie valérie fonio ouvrir
les archives il est aussi facile de le
dire que mal aisé de le faire les portes
de notre mémoire ont la réputation
d'être lourde surtout lorsqu'il s'agit
d'une page sombre de notre histoire
les questions sur ce 17 octobre 1961
sont durs y at il eu lors de cette
manifestation du fln contre le
couvre-feu imposé aux algériens et pour
l'algérie indépendante
trois morts selon le bilan officiel ou
200 ans et plus selon les travaux
récents d'historiens
y at il eu volonté politique ou non de
réprimer qui est responsable
police le préfet le gouvernement les
premières réactions sur cette ouverture
des archives celle des syndicats de
policiers sont partagés voire opposées
c'est la police nationale qui tout au
moins c'est ce qu'ils ressentent et qui
est mise en cause et je crois pas
qu'aujourd'hui fait tout au moins à ma
connaissance on puisse accuser la police
nationale de quoi que ce soit c'est une
institution qui fonctionne tout à fait
démocratiquement et qui est
véritablement une institution
républicaine et le vib le temps là le
temps final je crois que quand on
pratique le culte du secret quand tu ne
dis pas les choses c'est que ça cache
quelque chose
or je pense que nous n'avons absolument
rien à cacher n'avons pas à rougir de la
police nationale n'avons pas à rougir
d'autres nations nous n'avons pas à
rougir de la république française
un débat exacerbée par le procès de
maurice papon le préfet de police de
l'époque
hier pierre messmer ministre des armées
en 1961 le dédouaner de toute
responsabilité
aujourd'hui celui-ci applaudi à
l'ouverture des archives rappelle le
climat de l'époque celui de la guerre
d'algérie et apporte un bémol sur les
responsabilités à la responsabilité de
la décision de réagir fermement
pendant la manifestation c'est la
responsabilité du gouvernement et aucun
doute s'il y eut des bavures
c'est aussi la responsabilité du
gouvernement s'il ya eu des crimes ou
qui ont duré eu des crimes c'est tout
autre chose mais pour savoir il faut
trouver les archives notamment celle de
la préfecture de police
or celles ci sont légalement protégé
jusqu'en 2021
il faudra donc des circulaires peut-être
des lois et puis il faudra regrouper les
documents disséminés dans les différents
services de police que donneront ces
services aux archives
la vérité est sans doute au bout d'un
chemin encore très tortueux et le
ministre de la culture a précisé
aujourd'hui qu'une loi permettant
d'avoir accès aux archives serait
proposée dans le courant de l'année
prochaine
un millier de personnes se sont
rassemblées cet après midi sur le pont
saint-michel à paris pour commémorer
cette journée tragique d'octobre 61
un rassemblement qui s'est déroulé sans
incident mais aux cris de gbagbo
assassin de juifs d'algérie
au 8e jour du procès de maurice papon
raymond barre et olivier guichard cité
comme témoin devant la cour d'assises de
la gironde
olivier guichard affirment que le
général de gaulle avait absous au nom de
l'unité nationale l'ancien fonctionnaire
de vichy
compte rendu d'audience dominique
verdeilhan patrick de ma chère le visage
grave
empreint d'une certaine solennité
raymond barre pénètre dans le palais de
justice par une porte dérobée
il est rare qu'un ancien premier
ministre vienne témoigner devant une
cour d'assises pour un de ses anciens
ministres
maurice papon dit il a été un ministre
du budget dévoué efficaces compétents
royale raymond barre or en hommage aux
grands commis de l'état mais un juré
demande la parole saviez-vous ce
qu'avait fait maurice papon ici à
bordeaux sous l'occupation
vous êtes vous renseigné comme on le
fait quand on engage un employé non
répond raymond barre en 76 la réputation
de maurice papon était excellent
la déposition de l'ancien premier
ministre n'a pas excéder huit minutes
olivier guichard est fidèle à son image
de barons du gaullisme
l'ancien ministre rapport qu'il
confidences du général en 1958
ah oui papon c'est ce préfet de vichy
que j'ai rencontré à bordeaux en
septembre 44
il a rendu des services à la libération
tous les premiers ministres du général
poursuit olivier guichard ont été dans
la fonction publique de vichy et le
général ne voulait pas après la
libération qu'on fasse le procès de la
france
avec cet événement a quitté maurice
papon attendait certainement plus une
main tendue plus franches plus appuyé
une caution morale et politique derrière
sa vitre pare balles
maurice papon ne quittait pas des yeux
ses anciens collègues du gouvernement
seulement voilà aucun à diriger son
regard vers l'ancien min à pleine
fougères les tests génétiques destinés à
identifier le meurtrier de la jeune
anglaise caroline dickinson et bien ces
tests se sont révélés négatifs dans un
mois ce sont les hommes de 35 à 60 ans
qui seront soumis à une deuxième série
alors qu'une vaste campagne dans le nord
de la bretagne la manche concernera les
personnes soupçonnés ou condamnés pour
déviations sexuelles sur place jacques
devaux michel hiver
ce matin à l'heure du facteur la
nouvelle est tombée à pleine fougères
les 169 tests génétiques effectués sur
la population masculine de 15 à 35 ans
ont tous été négatifs
cela n'a pas vraiment été une surprise
pour la population ouais c'est rassurant
mais je pense que tout le monde le
savait que ça aurait été négatif levée
la suspicion sur le pont de plusieurs
bons je crois que c'est intéressant
compte tenu de la requête qui a été fait
sur le terrain pendant toute cette année
je ne voyais pas possible un résultat
positif mais il y aura une seconde série
de tests dans un mois cette fois sur les
35 60 ans ceux qui ont déjà subi les
tests n'y trouve rien à redire
je pense que ce n'ét est pour les autres
façons complètement son logis que c'est
quoi
et à vos yeux ce sera négatif aussi je
pense assure mail enquête ne se limite
pas à pleine fougères
les tests génétiques vont être étendues
on peut vous dire que les tests
continueront puisque tous les violeurs
de la région tous les agresseurs sexuels
voire les pédophiles pourront être
testés comme à son habitude renaud van
ruymbeke applique sa méthode ne jamais
rien négliger à nantes jean marc ayrault
président du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale
comparaissait ce matin devant le
tribunal correctionnel le député-maire
de nantes est poursuivi pour avoir
favorisé l'attribution de marchés
publics ou plan local reportage olivier
caroff marie-christine gomes trois mois
de prison avec sursis la peine requise
contre jean marc ayrault n'est pas
lourde mais le réquisitoire du procureur
et cévennes depuis ce matin le tribunal
correctionnel cherchent à savoir comment
le député maire ps de nantes s'y est
pris pour attribuer 13 millions de
francs de travaux d'impression et de
publicité à une entreprise de la région
sans appel d'offres et parfois même sans
un contrat le bénéficiaire de cet
étrange marché daniel n'était là
militants socialistes et patron de la
snep
la mairie lui avait confié la
fabrication du journal municipal mais
pour son avocat beaucoup d'autres
entreprises ont bénéficié depuis les
débats ont établi que les faits
reprochés à monsieur des deux est là et
la société snap au la société graffitis
ont été défaits commun et qu'ils ont
concerné un ensemble de sociétés faut
demander au ministère public pourquoi il
ne poursuit que monsieur et c'est là le
même tribunal a déjà condamné daniel
n'était là il ya un mois pour trafic
d'influencé il jouait un rôle
d'intermédiaire entre des entreprises du
btp et des élus locaux le résultat d'une
enquête menée en 1992 par le juge van
ruymbeke
selon lui n'étaient là étaient
intervenus dans près de 500 marchés
publics
jean marc ayrault lui proteste de sa
bonne foi sylla
en place une procédure pour éviter les
appels d'offres ce n'était pas pouvoir
briser tel ou tel mais pour créer dit il
un outil de communication efficace qui
lui vaut aujourd'hui cette mauvaise
publicité
et puis on vient d'apprendre
l'hospitalisation en urgence à paris de
l'ancien ministre et académicien jean
françois deniau
âgé de 69 ans jean françois deniau et
régulièrement soigner à l'hôpital
val-de-grâce à vitrolles une jeune
lycéenne de 18 ans a déposé plainte hier
pour injure à caractère raciste
l'adolescente qui venait s'inscrire au
lycée pierre-mendès-france
on aurait été fermement 10 fait des
reportages jacques cardoze jean-françois
giorgetti impossible de s'inscrire dans
cet établissement
sofia n'aurait pas le physique requis
c'est en tout cas ce que lui aurait
répondu la secrétaire du proviseur en
juin dernier la jeune fille venait alors
se renseigner des modalités
d'inscription pour une terminale
littéraire vous demander votre nom n'a
pas permis nal
je veux dire pour quelle raison elle
m'aurait dit ça parce que c'est pas sur
le physique on juge qu'il ya à
l'intérieur une scène et des propos
entendus par une mère d'élève
un témoin qui a décidé la jeune fille a
porté plainte pour propos injurieux à
caractère raciste aujourd'hui le mrap et
certaines fédérations de parents
d'élèves disent ne pas être étonné pour
eux se devait arriver compte tenu des
idées politiques et de la personnalité
du proviseur elle même je suis jointe
par téléphone madame le proviseur n'a
pas souhaité nous répondre quant au
rectorat d'académie il préfère attendre
les conclusions de l'enquêté menée
actuellement par l'éducation nationale
celles ci portent également sur le
climat et l'ambiance qui règne au sein
du lycée
ce qui m'inquiète c'est de voir se
dégrader non seulement
la confiance entre les personnels mais
également entre les élèves puisque
certains élèves qui jusqu'à présent
pouvait avoir des opinions racistes ne
se perd permettait pas maintenant ils
les proclame les résultats de l'enquêté
seront connus du ministre de l'éducation
nationale dont les jours prochains
quant à la justice elle devra se
prononcer avant la fin de l'année depuis
ce matin se déroulent un peu partout en
france les collections des représentants
des parents d'élèves un vote qui se fait
la plupart du temps par correspondance
cette année vaste campagne d'affichage
pour tenter de re motiver les parents
qui s'abstiennent une fois sur deux
reportages nathalie noise ans jacques
garnich le vote des adultes passent par
la main des enfants
les élus siégeront au conseil d'école
dans quelques semaines un rôle qui n'est
pas sans importance du vote du règlement
intérieur organisation des activités
périscolaires ou aménagement des rythmes
de travail dans cette école d'un
quartier privilégié le projet des
parents concerne aussi les espaces verts
les colas tellement de soucis que on
estime que ça fait partie un petit peu
notre notre souci parents nous
préoccuper de l'environnement nos
enfants moi je verrais bien quelques
quelques bancs peut-être un petit dans
le coin peut-être quelque chose qui soit
un petit peu en forme de demi
amphithéâtre pour que une maîtresse
puisse rassembler une dizaine d'enfants
lire dans le calme dans ce quartier plus
populaire les représentants des parents
ont d'autres soucis plus pratique
fermeture de classe lors des rentrées
précédentes problèmes d'inondations
cette année
cette évacuation d'eau qui a été refaite
qui a relativement peu de temps ne
fonctionne pas donc la cour est en
permanence inondé sitôt qu'il pleut et
nous allons lors du prochain conseil
d'école demandé au conseil d'école
d'émettre un voeu afin que ces travaux
soient faits ici les parents sont bien
associer la vie de l'école par le biais
d'ateliers de calligraphie mais pour les
enseignants chacun doit rester à sa
place s'il s'agit pas que les parents
soient tous les jours à l'école pour un
oui pour un non l'objectif n'est pas là
l'objectif est que les parents soient
attentifs
soucieux de la bonne scolarité de leurs
enfants dans ces deux exemples des
parents présents dans la vie de leur
école
mais cela n'empêche pas une faible
participation lors des élections
scolaires à l'assemblée nationale
poursuite du marathon budgétaire avec à
l'unanimité la suppression des
abattements professionnelle dont
bénéficie 72 profession à toulouse
boeing tentent une opération de
séduction auprès des ingénieurs
aéronautiques français le but est
clairement affichée débaucher les
meilleurs à travers une annonce parue
dans la presse régionale
une façon de faire ressenti comme
provocante dans la ville où aérospatiale
et airbus industrie représente un
véritable vivier de matière grise
muriel la saga gilles verizon
déstabiliser les industries
aéronautiques françaises voilà peut-être
ce qui se cache derrière l'annoncent
énigmatique d'une entreprise américaine
très secrète
c'est une petite astuce de leur part qui
consiste effectivement se servir d'une
société-écran salir le nom de bruyn
n'apparaît pas mais d'autres sans la
façon dont s'est présenté la plus grande
entreprise aérospatiale du monde permet
d'unification immédiate
c'est une récidive pour boeing qui l'an
passé avait tenté presque vainement de
débauché des ingénieurs toulousain un
recrutement que l'avionneur américain
effectue après avoir procédé à des
licenciements massifs en période de
crise c'est une démonstration
d'imprévoyance dans la gestion du
personnel qui est vraiment très
surprenante alors nous savons qu'ils ont
des problèmes ils ont des problèmes de
compétences de délai en ce moment de
cali
et c'est vraiment étonnant une
provocation bien ressenti à
l'aérospatiale beaucoup moins à airbus
industrie des portes qui claquent un
même scénario jouer cet après-midi par
boeing dont les sous-sols d'un grand
hôtel toulousain
le constructeur américain accueillez les
candidats pour une séance de quatre
heures d'obscurité vous voyez trouvé là
un premier - premier boulot ils
cherchent plus l'aspect connaissance
réelle acquise sur le terrain que les
diplômés et diplômées en plus donc
globalement on va en baver dit c'est
tout ce que j'ai fait et voir si sa peur
après 15 ans d'expérience en
électronique
cet homme touche actuellement 8500
francs nets par mois
l'attrait d'un salaire plus élevé c'est
certainement la meilleure carte à jouer
pour boeing en france
et puis l'on vient d'apprendre que le
deuxième vol d'ariane 5 est de nouveau
retardé de quelques jours à une semaine
en raison de problèmes techniques succès
indiscutable pour france télécom avec
plus de 3 millions huit cent mille
français qui se sont portés candidats à
l'achat d'actions de l'opérateur public
quant aux salariés d'entreprises plus de
cent mille d'entre eux se sont déclarés
intéressés
un score qui rejoint le succès jusqu
alors inégalées de paribas le prix exact
des cotisations des cotations par le nom
sera connu lundi prochain date à
laquelle le président de l'entreprise se
rendra à la bourse de new york
je vous propose maintenant de voir
l'actualité à l'étranger marque est bien
évidemment par la situation au congo 59
que sortie sans français et étrangers
ont été évacués aujourd'hui de dolisie
au sud du gong du congo vers le gabon au
cours d'une opération baptisée antilopes
par des commandos parachutistes français
basé à libreville
notre équipe dorothée olliéric et
philippe turpault a rencontré cet après
midi le nouvel homme fort du régime dans
le nord du congo denis sassou nguesso
qui a repris le pouvoir par les armes
reportage les miliciens cobras crient
victoire ce sont eux qui en 48 heures
ont pris brazzaville et puis pointe
noire avec l'aide des troupes angolaises
une conquête et claire du congo après
cinq mois de guerre civile
à quelque 400 kilomètres de la capitale
congolaise se trouve le fief de denis
sassou n'guesso
parmi ses invités un français conseiller
en communication de l'ancienne majorité
il est l'un des premiers à féliciter le
vainqueur militaire mais l'ancien
marxiste ne le cache pas il veut
relancer l'amitié franco congolaise
d'ailleurs il nous confiera que c'est
avec le président chirac qu'il était au
téléphone mais sans autre commentaire
la france ayant gardé une position de
neutralité pendant ce conflit congolais
avant sa conférence de presse denis
sassou n'guesso a accepté de nous livrer
ses premiers commentaires je me sens
pays sans armée mais système éducatif
arrêté le système sanitaire beaucoup de
travail mais nous allons mais de l'aude
un peu cela pour aller vers les
élections libres transparentes
la paix et pour un gouvernement d'union
nationale mady nationale est-ce que je
dois vous appelez président simon et
nous faisons tout pour aider notre pays
à sortir de la situation
et puis un temps appelé le président
aussi pendant plus de 12 ans aujourd'hui
vous allez vous autoproclamé président
ce parce qu'ils ne bloquent sa première
conférence de presse devant les médias
et les personnalités congolaises denis
sassou nguesso a annoncé son intention
de convoquer une conférence nationale
il a également dit que son gouvernement
serait connue dans les prochains jours
mais d'éventuels poches de résistance
dans le pays il n'a dit aucun mot en
espagne deux cent cinquante mille
manifestants protestaient hier soir dans
les rues de bilbao après la mort d'un
policier victime de letea nouveau
rassemblement pour marquer une fois
encore l'indignation de la population
contre l'assassinât de cet homme de 35
ans mortellement blessée lundi dernier
par un commando qui préparait un
attentat pour l'inauguration ce week end
du musée guggenheim
en présence du roi juan carlos à cuba
c'est aujourd'hui qu'ont eu lieu les
obsèques officielles de che guevara
présidée par fidel castro qui a rendu un
vibrant hommage à son ancien compagnon
d'armes tombés en bolivie il ya 30 ans
le che repose désormais dans un mausolée
de sept mètres de haut dans la petite
ville de santa clara au centre ville et
son argument
bon
venons en maintenant à la journée
mondiale contre la misère en quête de la
rédaction d'abord en france où là aussi
les chiffres sont accablants 5 millions
d'hommes et de femmes exclues près de 12
millions en situation de fragilité
économique pour atd quart monde le refus
de la misère c'est d'abord le respect
des droits fondamentaux pour les plus
démunis
une journée pour donner la parole à ceux
que la pauvreté a réduit au silence
reportage à mme guerry j'avais 21 ans et
demi maison puis du jour au lendemain
vous retrouver sans boulot juin
quelqu'un m'a fait le plus mal de perdre
mon emploi
je
états unis inutile je sentais que je
perdais ma dignité
son travail on perd sa dignité et que
les jambons et quand on a du travail
nous regardent différemment que quand on
appuie de travail quand on appuie de
travail pour eux on est des moins que
rien des bons à rien des feignants et
j'allais chez des gens dans mon village
une fois que j'ai perdu mon en mon
travail
les portes ils étaient fermés pour eux
je dis 'je te plus chez moi il ya patins
qu'il gaspille c'est pas de viande ne
s'est pas déplacé pas au mode où je fais
réchauffer pour le sort même parce que
moi j'ai appris à ne pas gaspiller
moi j'ai frôlé la pauvreté si vous
voulez misère non parce que j'avais mon
toit nous nous aimons motricité c'est de
toute différente entre la pauvreté la
misère la misère c'est que vous êtes
vraiment en bas de l'échelle
voilà vous n'avez plus rien du tout du
tout du tout du tout moi je suis que
dans la pauvreté point de vue finances
si vous voulez mais mon coeur est grand
parce que mots ceux qui sont dans la
pauvreté ça veut pas dire qu'ils n'ont
pas de coeur ils ont rien au contraire
dont ça se trouve un savoir beaucoup
plus grands que ceux qui tend un peu
plus russe que soit la perle que j'ai
c'est de perdre mon logement parce que
je m'étais sécher à la rue paul bert
pour ma part c'est terminé
on n'est rien on est comme une barque
allah dieu en personne à saint bonnet sa
dignité on n'a plus aucune motivation la
santé en prend un coup et plus j'avance
dans la bible n'est pas moi je me dis
que pour me dit toujours qu'on
comprendra la misère à binh celui qui
vit moi la seule chose que je sais c'est
que mes problèmes seraient des ronds
mais ça c'est difficile à faire passer
comme message
surtout quand une personne y c'est
presque ça d'état la rue
le second de cette journée gagner contre
la misère demande l'engagement de tous
un combat exigeante qui refusent
l'assistance où la charité à l'exemple
de ce polytechnicien qui a choisi d'agir
dans les bidonvilles de madrid and guéri
christophe airaud
on a besoin d'eux on n'a pas l'eau
courante alors quand on veut de l'ovale
à chercher tous les jours qu'il pleuve
ou non pas qu'ils transportent à bout de
bras ces 30 litres d'eau
deux kilomètres de bitume aller retour
c'est la seule route qui mène à la
fontaine c'est aussi la route des mille
camions
je voulais camions lors non ça va les
camions ils vont bente d'hérault c'est
quoi le brt 0 le 21 ça attention là
le brc des lots c'est la décharge est ok
de la décharge le bidonville le courant
tu n'arrives pas jusqu'ici l'électricité
non plus ils ne sont qu'à 20 minutes de
madrid
et pourtant trente familles sont privées
de tout oublier des assistantes sociales
et de l'administration
en fait les gens n'entrent pas dans le
quartier ise vite ici pourquoi ils ont
peur quand les vols quand les tubes
c'est le seul qui oc lui bruno compères
le volontaire français date était quart
monde il y a trente ans il était
polytechnicien mais un jour de mai 68 il
s'est engagé auprès des plus hauts
depuis quatre why we know et ses
bénévoles font la lecture aux enfants
la bibliothèque de rue c'est aussi un
peu une stratégie pour aider autrement
un quartier avec sur un ton qui n'est
pas l'assistance qui est l'avenir des
enfants l'avenir de famille et les gens
sont justement on veut autre chose pour
l'avenir
on a vraiment des ambitions ce film
délivre disent ils sur les meilleurs
livres qui sortent sur le marché les
deux sur le marché du livre de papier il
est où ton livre sur les chiens
très peu reçoivent des aides sociales
alors tout le monde travaille dans le
bidonville plus ou moins angel fond de
la ferraille comme la plupart des hommes
les autres vendent des cartons un peu de
récupération beaucoup de débrouille tout
cela pour une poignée reset avait fait
trop 4017 glace et comme quoi avec 4000
les états où pouvez-vous nous en dire
autant dire ces métiers leur permettent
de vivre en dehors de toute insertion
sociale pour atd quart monde il est
nécessaire de prendre en compte cette
manière de subsister qui va à l'encontre
des politiques d'imaginer par les
gouvernements européens
ici en espagne on sent une forte
pression des pays du nord pour se
réaliser comme on dit ça va dire
réprimer le travail au noir et le marché
le second marché du travail et moi j'ai
peur que ça se fasse sans tenir compte
du fait que c'est ça qui permet la
survie des pauvres et leur dignité qu'il
faut absolument penser les choses en
prenant en compte l'expérience des plus
hauts
parce que sinon on aboutirait d'une part
à affamer les plus pauvres et d'autre
part à leur proposez quoi la pauvreté
des pays du nord c'est à dire
l'assistance la dépendance des oeuvres
et du travail social c'est pas un cadeau
grâce à une multitude de petits boulots
angel a pu se construire une maison en
dur
la seule du bidonville
depuis six ans il demande un logement en
vain la municipalité fait la sourde
oreille
en fait on va rester ici car ici nous
sommes des oubliés la bonne raison qu'on
n'existe pas il considère que n'existent
pas les enfants n'existe j'ai quatre
enfants ici il ya plus de 70 ans
mais il répète toujours qu'on n'existe
pas ne cherchez pas las barranquilla sur
une carte pour la municipalité de madrid
ce quartier n'existe pas ici on vit
depuis 20 ans sans adresse en france et
pour financer son action atd quart monde
a mis en place la péréquation 2000
personnes donnent régulièrement une
partie de leur salaire à cette
association ville martine et claude
barnier ils habitent hors de paris vient
au travail en voiture et s'engouffre
dans un immeuble ultramoderne rien dans
le trajet quotidien de cet ingénieur de
travaux publics mais susceptible de
choquer sa conscience pas de sans
domicile fixe en vue pas de
sollicitations répétition et pourtant
depuis de longues années
jérôme geoffrey fait partie de ceux qui
luttent contre la pauvreté
c'est pas nécessaire d'aller d'aller
habiter dans un quartier
délabré pour se sentir concerné par la
pauvreté je crois que on ne pourra faire
vraiment quelque chose contre la
pauvreté que si vraiment tout le monde
se sent concerné jérôme est un allié atd
quart monde nomme ainsi ceux qui ont
accepté qu'une partie de leurs revenus
mensuels soit versée automatiquement sur
le compte de l'association les alliés
choisi ce montant de la somme pour
jérôme cela représente 5% du salaire de
l'argent qui permet de rétribuer les
trois cent cinquante volontaires qui eux
ont choisi de vivre parmi les plus
pauvres de l'argent qui permet aussi
d'écrire et de diffuser l'histoire des
exclus la géant j'ai dans les mains un
livre qui est en fait une série
d'histoires de famille et le mouvement
tient beaucoup à faire exister ces
familles à faire exister leur histoire
parce que les plus pauvres n'ont pas
d'histoire
ils vivent ils disparaissent personne ne
se souvient qu'ils ont vécu qu'ils ont
peiné et fait foncièrement injuste
la journée de lutte contre la pauvreté
ce fut aussi cela la collecte dans ces
grands livres d'une multitude de
témoignages sur des vies blessés à tout
autre sujet à présent ce week-end le
bois de vincennes accueillera le salon
des arts martiaux des sports de combat à
cette occasion laurent frédéric bollée
et eric de l'agneau ont rencontré une
jeune femme surprenante mannequin mais
aussi championne du monde de kick boxing
tu passes à poigne
oh que non elle n'est vraiment pas celle
que vous croyez et ce n'est pas parce qu
on la surprend en pleine séance
d'essayage qu'il faut s'arrêter aux
apparentes
chantal ménard 27 ans est mannequin là
ça se voit mais elle est aussi
championne du monde de kick boxing et là
ça surprend un peu
même s'il ya finalement des combats à
tous les niveaux le bayer a beaucoup de
différence entre un combat sur un ring
et faire le métier de mode parce que ses
essais et ses combattre tout le temps
liang une compétition et des combats
internes incroyable le kickboxing donc
un sport né en 1974 appelait autrefois
foulletons taxer la réunion du karaté et
de la boxe anglaise
c'est à 22 en défilant sur un ring que
chantal a découvert cette discipline
cinq ans plus tard à raison de cinq
heures d'entraînement par jour
elle devient championne du monde c'était
au mois de mai à san francisco là on ne
plaisante plus
l'engagement de ces dames n'a rien à
envier à celui des hommes jean ce côté
un petit peu macho qui fait que laurent
bon c'est une fille mais vous savez
quand on met les gants avec les filles
quand on les entraîne on s'aperçoit que
jean d'une frappe sèche
elles ont une très très bonne discipline
de vie elles ont une très très grande
précision donc une grande efficacité
les femmes et les arts martiaux une
pratique en plein boom on y travaille la
souplesse l'absence dans une optique de
non-violence sa famille mais sport n'est
pas violent n'existe pas personne
quand le sport non n'allez quand même
pas embêtés chantal ménard elle aurait
de quoi se défendre
d'ailleurs on a oublié de vous le dire
elle est aussi gardes du corps et la
protéger entre autres david bowie et
michael jackson
il y en a qui ont vraiment de la chance
les mannequins de chez chanel n'ont pas
forcément l'agilité de la championne du
monde de kickboxing mais elles ont la
grâce des filets ce matin en six
tableaux pour une superbe rétrospective
de la grande maison revisité par karl
lagerfeld et kenzo cet après-midi jouets
lawrence d'arabie pour une collection
autour du désert reportage nicole cornu
langlois frédéric de la rue c'est un
hommage à chanel que nous présente karl
lagerfeld en reprenant tous les thèmes
qui firent sa gloire
depuis qu'elle créa sa griffe en 1916
voici ses célèbres tailleurs tweet
pastel ses colliers géant ses robes
libéré d' entrave c'est par dessus des
structures et avec leurs coiffures
extravagantes les mannequins leur donne
une allure plus envie d'une sorte de
regard espiègle sur un passé prestigieux
et thème très précis qui une façon non
chronologique nom historique évoque la
démarche chanel revit pas le goût de
l'eau puisqu'elle est elle aussi figure
de riscle biarritz que chanel avant
chanel et c'est l'été les channel de
coco j'ai fait un peu ils nourrissent
tic en même temps est-il vraiment
nécessaire d'imprimer le nom sur la robe
pour reconnaître le style
non car chanel c'est une évidence c'est
un état d'esprit que cette collection
rétrospective a remis au goût du jour
en lui redonnant dijon du piquant
imaginaire différents pour kenzo les
mirages du sahara lui inspire un univers
de métissage haut en couleurs robe
foulard noir et bleu touareg les pieds
dans le sable et le soleil dans la tête
ces fameuses les mélange étrange joue
avec le feu d'une jupe à rio bravo kenzo
pour cette collection époustouflante qui
nous donne envie de partir tout de suite
vers un ailleurs plus libre plus
lumineux plus chaleureux tels que vous
savez la vente et avant de refermer ce
journal l'exposition de pierre-yves
trémois qui a laissé pointant le dessin
et la peinture pour s'attaquer à la
sculpture et aux céramiques avec pour
modèle la plastique parfaite du chanteur
vedette des toupies flux et reportages
georges bégoux pascal couillaud pour le
monde de l'art de l'institut dont il est
membre voir ainsi que pour le grand
public très mois est avant tout un aigle
du dessin la gravure lui a apporté la
notoriété mais depuis quelques années le
goût du volume l'a conduit à sculpter
des corps bien modelés comme celui de
philippe chanteur vedette des to be free
un événement qu'il manque pas d'attirer
les photographes d'une presse assez
éloignée du journal des arts shs
immortalisé quelque part dans le bronze
pour l'exercice et on est dans le rond
pour l'éternité
non mais j'ai très peur j'espère qu'on
fera d'autres beaucoup d'autres même
consacré au couple et à l'ex-star
l'extase
la grande affaire de traitement
moi j'adore les kobe je peux rester des
journées entières les chiens voyeur
terrier vend le mieux regarder des
corses et ses fabuleux et je trouve que
c'est dommage qu'à notre époque c'était
90% de la peinture de la sculpture le
corps depuis des millénaires et il a été
abandonnée on ne sait pas très bien
pourquoi on ne fait que des corps
matraquer 10 tortue c'est plus facile de
hurler que de chanter juste et avec chez
ce bout de terre d'argile
comment symboliser l'extase la réponse
nous semble de mai et le monde animal
est aussi de la fête car très mois
éprouve une fascination pour les animaux
et particulièrement pour le monde
aquatique auquel il a consacré une
centaine de céramique créé à valleau des
céramiques qui constitue le deuxième
volet de son exposition espace châtelet
victoria sous forme de vase ou de coupe
ses thèmes favoris se déclinent et
s'entremêlent j'ai fait beaucoup de
coupes
parce que je pensais que c'était un peu
comme introduire de la lumière et
l'émail donne cette lumière que je
recherche
même en céramique avec très mois on en
revient toujours au dessin pour coiffer
à distré si on peut en faire que deux
c'est pour ça que le burin me plaît
beaucoup c'est que c'est une incision on
ne peut pas se tromper at repentir très
moi même pas le repentir il préfère
recommencer et chercher sans cesse des
émotions nouvelles comme un pêcheur
d'image
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous en
rappelle les principaux titres le
gouvernement décide d'ouvrir les
archives sur la manifestation
d'algériens d'octobre 61
les tests génétiques effectuées à pleine
fougères pour tenter d'identifier le
meurtrier de caroline dickinson sont
tous négatifs
enfin congo scènes de joie et de
pillages à brazzaville le nouvel homme
fort denis sassou nguesso présente son
programme politique
je vous remercie de votre attention dans
un instant la météo il label martinez
encore une belle journée demain puis le
poids route de valérie maurice prochaine
édition
23h50 bruno roger-petit de master dans
thé ou café catherine ceylac recevra
jean new pdg de l'afp est excellente fin
de soirée sur france 2 j'aurai le
plaisir de vous retrouver demain 20
heures
au tout